is
inconsolable after hearing of her
mother's death
while waiting in line to get oxygen for
her
i want to go to my mother she cries
repeatedly
earlier she described just how difficult
it is to get help in delhi
we have been out of our house since two
in the morning there's no oxygen
available in
all of delhi and after a lot of running
around we finally got here by around
four
initially there was a queue on the other
side then we were told that we had to
come to the front side and cue here
my mother is very ill and for the past
two days we've been trying to get a bed
in so many hospitals in delhi
[Music]
shruthi's mother is just one of the 3645
people who died in india on wednesday
delhi remains one of the worst affected
states its leader said despite trying
their best
every hospital in the capital is
overburdened and treating people beyond
their capacity
that's why this space in central new
delhi where political rallies and
religious
festivals are usually held is being
converted into a makeshift hospital
this is where the government is
constructing a 500 bed intensive care
unit facility
it hopes to have an extra 1200 icu beds
in the capital
within two weeks but that's still
nowhere near enough to meet the numbers
needed right now
delhi's cases are going up by more than
twenty thousand each day
and health experts say around fifteen
percent of people with the virus
need to be in hospital the u.s state
department tweeted saying access to
medical care is severely limited due to
covert 19 cases
and u.s citizens who wish to depart
india should use the available
commercial flights
now but despite the country going
through its worst crisis in its modern
history
the last phase of regional elections
went ahead in the state of west bengal
on thursday
where four candidates have already died
from the virus
in the context of a raging pandemics
it's unconscionable
that people should be called to vote
today particularly in the city of
calcutta
where the positive the positivity rate
of rt pcr test is currently at 50
percent
health experts say the devastating
scenes witnessed in other states
will be repeated in west bengal as a
result of the large political gatherings
elizabeth paranam al jazeera new delhi